so our next speaker besides being a
fan of stan which we clearly like at
this conference
she also loves loops
she loves loops in r which some of us
might
be scared by
but if you do them right they're not
necessarily slower they have a bad rep
but if you do them right they're not
necessarily bad
but she's also a fan of loops in music
and she even has
a looper to put her voice over her
recordings and the looper's name is
lupita
so
everyone please welcome to the stage
miyari
hi um my name is majeri and i also go by
may
and i'll be talking about my experience
handling the missing data of a
randomized control trial with syrian
refugee children using tools in r
so
first i'm going to give you just a
little bit of context about our study
and the challenges that it presented us
then i'll do an overview of the method
that i use
um
and i'll explain some of the tools and
strategies that were helpful to navigate
the main challenges
and then i'll illustrate the
implications of missing data on some of
our results
the international rescue committee and
nyu global ties for children have
conducted several trials to test the
impact of a program for displaced
children in conflict-affected regions
and the program basically offered
support for their academic and their
emotional development
and
one of those trials was conducted in
lebanon with syrian refugee kids which
is the data that i will be telling you a
little bit more about today
the study relied on survey data and it
involved different assessments that
covered multiple aspects of the
children's circumstances and development
and there were three waves of data
collection
the goal was that this data could cater
to multiple research questions and
analysis that would contribute to our
understanding of these programs and of
these children's development in a
comprehensive way
but these populations are fairly
different from those that have been used
in the past to generate most of the
evidence base that we have about child
development in the western world
and so
the education and child development
experts at nyu aim to cover
all possible ground in terms of
collecting background information
it's also worth noting that this is a
context where rigorous data collection
is very difficult to implement
due to security threats
due to the children's migration patterns
and also due to the lack of id
documentation for tracking them
so
we ended up with over 900 potentially
relevant items to account for
of which over 800 had missing data
and one of the first challenges is
how do we leverage all of that
potentially relevant information in a
context where we know so little and for
which we may have culturally inadequate
biases
and so we want to have a way
to also reflect in our final analysis
how cautious we should be about our
results due to the missing data
and data quality also varied across
different features due to volatile
circumstances in the field
and on top of that we had items at the
site level at the teacher level and at
the student level
as well as a bunch of items that
depended on skip logic or had weird
applicability dependencies
all things that can make addressing the
missing data a little bit less
straightforward
but
why is missing data even a problem
when we have missing data for some
participants there is always a very good
chance that their data is missing
because of important differences between
people
which can cause people that face
specific circumstances to be under or
overrepresented in our results so
basically the results risk being biased
but also
data is usually costly to collect right
and if you leave out the incomplete
cases from your study you'll be throwing
away very valuable information
and if we're going to burden vulnerable
populations with lengthy surveys
on top of the financial cost we also
have a moral responsibility to make the
best possible use of their data
um okay so
to make sure that everyone has a sense
of what's going on moving forward i'll
do a quick overview of the method
that i use to address the missing data
and first
if this is a new word for you imputation
basically means creating predictions or
best guesses for the missing information
there are many ways to go about imputing
and my choice was multiple imputation
through chained equations or chained
models i think chain models makes more
sense
this approach basically allows us to use
all the available information from each
participant to build a predictive model
for each variable that has missing data
and to create an educated guess that is
powered by your data
of what the unobserved responses might
look like
so for a second let's just pretend that
we have a super simple data set
with only a few variables
and the red cells indicate missing
information
so we start by
filling in random starting points in
place of the missing values
and then build a model for any one
variable say income
and this replaces our missing values in
income with something that is better
than just noise
and
then we can use all the available
information and our income variable with
imputations that are already better than
noise to build a predictive model for
another variable
and now instead of missing values we
have better than noise predictions for
two of our variables and we can build a
model to get even better predictions for
a third item with missing data
and so we get to a point where
we have educated guesses for all the
missing data powered partially by noise
but partially by all the observed
information from our data set
and we can keep on improving these
predictions by iterating this process
using better and better predicted values
in place of the missing data and
that is basically what we refer to as
chained models or chained equations
so
where does the
multiple part in multiple invitation
come from
it comes from repeating this full
process
multiple times but starting with
different noisy values that could lead
us to end
in slightly different places
this results in
us getting
many different completed data sets with
different final predictions for the
missing values
and i think it helps to think about them
as all the possible universes that we
can imagine
given what we were able to observe
but
let's go back to our real world data and
challenges
if we're using the mice approach to deal
with the missing data and we want to
stay humble on what we don't know about
a new context
then we may want to allow for the
possibility that any of the features
that our experts thought to collect data
on could play a role in predicting any
one variable or in explaining why some
of its information is missing
but this implies building very costly
models
that account for tons of features
and then we'd have to fit those costly
models for the hundreds of variables
that have missing data
and then because
missingness rates in data quality
variety across items
you may also want to iterate for as long
as it takes the last variable to
converge
and also you may want to make sure that
you produced enough imputed sets to get
a good estimation of the uncertainty for
all the variables that will be used for
any analysis
but all of this is super computationally
costly and time consuming to run
so
one of the strategies that i found
helpful to reduce time and resources
with no apparent loss in the quality of
the imputations was to
simply do a little bit of feature
selection before computing
specifically i found the boruta package
helpful
this is a wrapper of the random forest
method which most of you are probably
familiar with already if you're not just
know that random forest is a machine
learning algorithm that you can use to
build predictive models without having
to make
a bunch of assumptions about the
functional form that relates the
predictors with the outcome
it also rates the predictor's
importance
and
the boruta package uses the importance
scores produced by random forest
not only to rank the features but also
to help estimate which ones don't really
add any predictive value
the general idea is that it creates fake
copies of all the variables but with
their values all shuffled so that the
fake copies are just noise features with
no true predictive value
then it lets random forest score the
importance of both the real and the fake
features
and by comparing the important scores of
the real variables with those that we
know to be purely noise
it gives us suggestions of which
variables should be accepted or rejected
as having any predictive value
but
there is a catch
like most feature selection tools out
there
you need to feed it complete data
which at this point you still don't have
because that's exactly what we are
trying to address
um
so
the practical get around that i used for
this was
just to fill in the missing entries with
noise
then
run boruta with each variable that had
missing data as the outcome
and also
run boruta with a non-response
indicators as the outcome
so we can take into account the features
that are related to the probability of
missing that information
and
then i just took a conservative approach
when discarding predictors i flagged for
any one variable
only those that came back as completely
useless both to predict the variable
itself and the probability that it's
missing
here
for example you can see
which of the features on the x-axis were
found to have no predictive value for
the items of a math assessment
green indicates the count of math items
that a feature had predicted value for
and so you can already see how by
leaving all these uninformative features
out from each model iteration of the
math items you'll save resources
the software tools that i found most
helpful to implement multiple imputation
were the well-known mice package
and mice ads which complements a lot of
the functionality of mice
some of the appeal of these packages is
that they can handle mixed types of data
and multi-level imputation which allows
us to get predictions that are
consistent when we had missingness at
both the teacher and the student levels
um they also allow for a good amount of
flexibility and control over what goes
into the models
our data also had a bunch of
applicability restrictions and skip
logic patterns
at both the teacher and the student
levels and the flexibility of these
tools helped us prevent
predictions from happening where they
shouldn't be happening
also
these packages offer several options
when it comes to choosing the types of
models that you want to fit in each
iteration of mice
i decided to go with random forest
because it's significantly faster than
linear models
it naturally accounts for interactions
and non-linearities
it prevents us from making too many
assumptions about the data generating
process in a culturally different
setting where we know very little
and it is also consistent with the
feature selection process which is nice
one of the ways
in which mice offers flexibility is the
control that it gives you over the
predictor matrix
there you can make a bunch of
specifications of what goes into each
model and which variables are at what
level of nesting
and before getting started you can
automatically use the flags from your
feature selection process to populate
the predictor matrix
and you can exclude a bunch of features
that are unhelpful for each variable
that will be imputed
it was also helpful to create objects
that indicate applicability dependencies
i use those to
automatically create interaction terms
and populate the predictor matrix
and this ensured that
all the applicable items for each
student
could be used to power the imputation
models
even when applicability varied across
students
another object
that helps complement this functionality
is the where matrix
which allows to specify areas of the
sample for which invitations are not
applicable
and then there are the objects that
allow you to specify how to model each
variable
the math vector
is where you should specify the method
that should be used for the lower level
items or the student level items in our
case or where you specify
which variable is a level two item or a
teacher level item
or you can also specify
if a variable should be passively
imputed and then the imputation function
list should contain the modeling
approach that you want for only the
teacher level or level two variables
and lastly for those teacher variables
the clustering id needs to be specified
as a list in the cluster bar object
and
once you have carefully populated all
those objects you can run mice and get a
bunch of the parallel universes that are
possible for your data
we produced 100 to be safe
i'm not going to dive into this but just
know that
after you're done computing you would
have to make sure that your imputations
are converging and blending properly
and
you may want to check that there are no
obvious lingering differences between
respondents and non-respondents
once you have conditioned on all the
relevant features
and then you'll be ready to
do your analysis and get a better sense
of
the role that missing data played in the
conclusions that you can draw from it
here i'm showing you the estimated
average treatment effect
on just four of our outcomes after we
pulled the results we got from the
different imputed data sets
where here our credible intervals
already reflect the uncertainty brought
in by the missing data
and in the plots below you can see how
much the results varied across different
predicted worlds
and
you can see that for some of our
outcomes the results were pretty
consistent across imputed sets
while for other outcomes the results
varied importantly
meaning that
we can't have as much certainty about
the impact of the program on those two
outcomes because of the missing data
and so we should be more careful when
making recommendations about those
outcomes
so
just some takeaways if you are
dealing with social data
missing data is almost inevitable
and it gets worse with vulnerable
populations
so
i think the responsible thing to do is
to make an effort to assess the damage
that missing data can have on your
ability to answer your original research
questions
and multiple computation provides a nice
framework to do that
mice mice ads boruta and random forest
packages in r can help you navigate some
of the challenges if you're dealing with
complex social data
and
it is important to try to be aware and
transparent about what you can and what
you cannot learn from your data
if anyone has questions for me or if you
just want someone to vent with about
your own missing data misadventures
feel free to reach me at
mmd486 at
nyu.edu
thank you
thank you very much for that talk uh it
was wonderful um
and that's an example of finding someone
at one of our events and then he had to
become a speaker
i think that is a wonderful thing when
that happens
that was a great talk i hope everyone
enjoyed that